my name is Jason cocky and I'm a blogger
I grew up in rural Wisconsin lived on a
farm I moved there when i was about to i
was born in in the twin cities in
minnesota and yeah i lived there from
about two until i was 18 and then went
out to off to college and and things
like that um it wasn't it wasn't a
working farm it was just sort of a it
was a place in the in the country and my
dad rented out the farmland to other
people and they farmed it but basically
grew up on a farm without the cows I
don't know I think New York I currently
live in New York and I think New York is
sort of full of people who have come
from the Midwest to sort of seek their
fortune whether that's financial or
cultural or whatever seek their fortune
in New York City and you know I think I
feel a lot of kinship with those people
in that you know growing up I was sort
of curious and interested in a lot of
things and and and you sort of I don't
know I had it had a had a city sort of
temperament even though I lived in a
rural area I went to went to college in
Cedar Rapids Iowa at coe college which
is one of the small liberal arts schools
that sort of litter Iowa and I had this
friend that he was from the Twin Cities
and he said you you seem to be a city
guy to me like you don't it doesn't seem
like you belong in the country I think
my dad was a big influence he's had a
billion different jobs you know soon he
was I think when he got out of college
she was or he actually didn't finish
college but when he sometime around that
time he was in the Navy and he want to
fly airplanes and he eventually became
pilot ran his own company his own
airline like cargo commuter freight
business and he was an engineer and he
just did a lot of different things get a
lot of different interests and a lot of
different things that he could do and he
always I don't know he made sure that my
sister and I took an interest in sort of
the world around us and you know explain
to us why why the sky was blue and
and he bought us a World Book
Encyclopedia when we were young and I
used to just sit for hours and hours and
hours and read the Encyclopedia like
just pick out a volume at random and
just start reading and like reading
through and you know just always kept me
interested particularly in science and
things like that I was a physics major
in college and you know I think that
interest you know comes right from him